[Música]
eu e minha mulher estamos muito fazer
três ou quatro coisas e mais algumas ler
comer viajar e e em um certo sentido de
humor e três dessas quatro coisas
fazemos muito fãs do fmi importante
penso que é um sonho um chefe e
apresentador de televisão que vocês
conhecem e que nós acompanhávamos todos
os dias através de uma explosão das
redes sociais
eu ia eu sigo os que eu no twitter
a ministra me ambos no no facebook e no
em outubro
nós sabemos muito sobre a sobrevida do
fmi importante tinha tinha sido chefe
tenha deixado cozinhar
ainda senti que tinha se casado duas
vezes que na altura em que são seu ano
passado com você estava em tinha uma
namorada italiana que caiu cerca três
vezes a portugal
os açores são paulo foi o porto onde
ficou relativamente valorizado com o
tamanho conteúdo de uma francesinha
quando é fã de verdade morreu o ano
passado é a minha show e eu também vou
ter uma mais do que uma figura da
televisão mais do que alguém que nós
vimos não é
era alguém que com o qual nós sentimos
tenhamos alguma intimidade concentrava
todos os dias por nossa nossa vida a
nossa a nossa nosso espaço na nossa casa
e que nós sentimos que fazer é quase
como um amigo nosso né
e na verdade que o que eu fria e aí e
quantidade de coisas que nós sabemos
sobre a sobrevida de al ain
nós sabemos hoje em dia muito pouco
sobre as pessoas com quem convivemos no
dia a dia eu sequer a não sair eu não
conheço o suficiente
mais de meia dúzia de pessoas para saber
o nível de intimidade
o nível de conhecimento que tinha sobre
a sobrevida do df de guardar e isso é
acho que é uma realidade com todos nós
conseguimos funcionários seja qualquer
pessoa hoje em dia consome muitos
conteúdos digitais através de ter creche
nomeadamente através desse top top mas
principalmente através do esporte fontes
em algum momento é nos últimos dez anos
em que quase duplicou mais do que
duplicou o o o espaço o tempo que nós
gastamos em no smartphone
estamos em em canais digitais é possui
conteúdos digitais dias aumento foi
quase todo o eu é realizado em
smartphones nós hoje em dia vemos é
conteúdos vemos no trabalho vemos em
casa
vemos e vivemos e grande parte da nossa
vivência gemia feita à volta a volta do
smartphone
nada disto é muito diferente vocês podem
pensar nós já temos a criança antes nós
já tínhamos a prisão todos nós também já
o português médio gasta cerca de quatro
horas diárias também haverá a ver
televisão dias por lesão também tem as
suas estrelas também tem os seus
os seus iphones guardadas as suas suas
dietas e todos nós já tínhamos uma certa
relação com essas com essas pessoas na
televisão é a minha avó sempre sentava
haver um sinal das oito tinham cazaque
afrontava o que se passa avó está com
frio e ela não é como senhora da
televisão está todo investido eu não
posso ficar atrás
mas apesar de tudo é diferente e é
diferente por várias razões
a primeira delas eu diria que é um tema
definir as enquanto que a televisão é
com esse aumento o planalto massa se
comunica e cria muitas vezes de prensas
e séries que toda a gente vê toda a
gente vai dar forma ao mesmo tempo a
capacidade de finalização uma capacidade
é segmentação que os canais digitais que
a internet tem permitido chegar aos
segmentos mais específicos aos nichos
mais pequenos que existem em todo o
mundo seja nós põe que é uma alternativa
no japão essencialmente mas hoje em dia
e quem vai é um é uma feira daniel
alguma falha já veio o dinheiro
a quantidade de pessoas que de repente
voaram faz de nós põe seja sermos fácil
de uma pessoa do nível 2 de sangue joga
em prática
tenho uma coisa muito difícil seja o
rainieri quem sabe quem é o rim está
aqui no canto inferior esquerdo raniery
é tem compete desde há cerca de três
anos com a disney com o maior número de
visualizações no youtube
basicamente o que eu faço é desembrulhar
e experimentar brinquedos e com isso
conseguiu nos últimos três anos ter
cerca de mil milhões de visualizações de
vídeos deus e em é publicidade é do
youtube que ele arrumar que continha 22
milhões de dólares que já não tenham
mais os pais das crianças que andam a
trabalhar cansa de 70
basicamente é o ranking tem essa
comunidade e seguidores
o outro que temos é o que chamo jackson
no vídeo também não sei se vocês já
viram mas basicamente são vídeos em que
filma pessoas a ver vídeos no youtube e
pois nada a ver vídeos de pessoas a ver
vídeos ea reação dessas pessoas a ver os
vídeos e como estas a outras a outras
comunidades pequenas de com afinidade eu
procurei meias de automobilistas com fé
nisso é eu não consegui encontrar mas a
verdade é que esta afinidade criamos e
efetivamente uma proximidade muito
grandes opções
não determinado gosto e porque não sabe
sabe que entre outras coisas são
resolvidas o frustrado por isso a minha
a minha comunidade a minha tribo
específica sobre técnicas de cinema aqui
mais especificamente sobre a técnica de
montagem enquadramento cena do cinema
que é uma coisa que eu gosto e preciso
também tenho os meus canais que eu sigo
e que enquanto no mundo inteiro cerca de
16 pessoas que seguem os mesmos
além da afinidade mas com uma grande
diferença é o bico isace a televisão é
aquilo que nós tínhamos em casa e
queremos normalmente assistir quando não
estamos a trabalhar num aumento de manhã
enquanto a visa tomar o pequeno-almoço o
fim do dia depois de chegar do trabalho
isso não é o caso do smartphone o
smartphone está conosco todo via
smartphone por meio do uso vara do
trabalho para casa ea casa para o
trabalho
o smartphone é o que nós usamos pra ver
hoje em dia com conteúdos digitais
principalmente filmes pequenos prevê
notícias pra ver fotos pra ver sua
família movimento para fazer operações
bancárias para fazer chamadas de vídeo
para utilizar nossas o nosso batimento
cardíaco número de passos que damos
todos os dias para controlar a música
para ouvir música
essa urbe cuidado com os smartphones têm
na nossa vida cria uma intimidade de
frente com aquilo que nós consumimos no
nosso moto no nosso som é basicamente
isso cria o que nós é normalmente
chamamos uma experiência simas seja nós
hoje temos a capacidade de viajar de
avião já cá pagar os impostos é
movimentar nossa conta bancária
tudo no telemóvel de uma forma
encomendar comida para casa tudo uma
forma símbolos sem infecção e
principalmente sem ter que falar com
outras pessoas e isso por 1 a 0 tem um
aspecto muito positivo porque cria e
dá-nos confiança e da nossa capacidade
de sermos donos cada vez mais nosso
próprio tempo
nós sabemos e decisivo com quem queremos
usar
mas também cria uma vertente menos
positiva que é uma lógica quase descenso
é de essa fricção que existe hoje em dia
é algo que nós precisamos porque sem
essa fricção sem essa capacidade de
tropeçar no via com outras pessoas e com
pessoas diferentes
são pessoas de outros estratos sociais
outras sete linhas de com outras
empresas com outros gostos é que o que
gera empatia com o próximo
na verdade hoje em dia nós estamos
maioritariamente mais conectados com as
nossas tribos globais com os quais nós
vivemos em casa no trabalho todos os
dias e que nos são próximas e vivemos -
com aquilo que são as nossas comunidades
locais tropeçamos - nós tropeçamos -
elas podemos empatia
queremos empatia com que o que é
diferente temos empatia com aqui há uns
que são diferentes e quando desperta a
simpatia e quando essa perda de
simpatias torna endêmica
nós já sabemos basicamente com as
conseqüências disse
mas então o que vamos fazer
vamos pegar em toda a tecnologia e vamos
deitar hoje vamos regressaram passava o
edílico entre toda a gente estava então
a gente conhecia os vizinhos toda a
gente estava bem com os vizinhos o que
se algum de vós alguma vez participou
numa assembléia condomínios sabe que não
é propriamente é verdade né
alguém acha que vemos notícias não
aumentar sempre em portugal existem
muito poucos os momentos mas alguém que
quer saber exatamente tiros nome à tv
como estão sempre do vizinho guiné não o
objetivo não é efetivamente se adaptar a
tecnologia hoje mas temos que
efetivamente recuperar um pouco da
fricção na nossa vida temos que
encontrar forma de voltar a ter de
voltar a tropeçar e voltar a encontrar
pessoas diferentes de voltar a fazer e
reconquistar alguma empatia com aquelas
pessoas que não via a dia têm três têm
diferenças comuns
vamos dar três sugestões
a primeira tem a ver com os preços
partilhados é essas presas partilhados
são comunidades que segregam que se
reúnem que se juntam em torno ou não em
três como houve uma necessidade
quando eu digo em 3 comum pode ser
partilham um sofá partilham o seu povo
se toca como sabemos é algo que nos
envolve emocionalmente pode ser algo que
pode ser o teto xixi é uma unidade que
temos é uma forma de reunir pessoas e
contactar pessoas de origens diferentes
mas algo que junte e que seja por uma
questão de em três por uma questão de
gosto
joão pessoas com origem muito bom
estamos encontrar um mecanismo agregador
mas esse mecanismo agregador serve pra
jantar opções grandes frutos
a segunda pode ser porém será apreciado
por exemplo andar transportes públicos e
quem incita andar de transportes
públicos que sabemos que o caraças nesta
imagem em sentimento contactar todos os
dias com outras pessoas que andam
transportes ponte alcan por necessidade
têm que frequentar 3200 seja uma
repartição de finanças cada vez menos o
irã social acrescenta todos os chips
nessas pessoas junto a segunda ideia tem
a ver com perspectiva e reconquistar a
perspectiva relativamente aquilo que nós
somos e arrogância que nós temos nós não
somos importantes nós quebram nós é um
grande herói a crise no planeta que é um
grande área numa gaiola numa galáxia que
é um grande área no universo muito fácil
nós temos que efetivamente conquistar
alguma perspectiva relativamente à nossa
infância a nossa falta de importância da
tecnologia tornou os mimados
nós hoje em dia principalmente com os
canais digitais como a internet tem essa
capacidade e personalização de o mundo
se reconfigurar a nossa volta
nós hoje em dia sentimos que somos o
centro do mundo que abrimos uma página
do facebook tal a todo consentrans que
pesquisamos no facebook que tava tudo
com o sinttrans e nós temos que perder
por verdes conquistaram porque sempre
ativa e de perceber que nós não somos
efetivamente o mundo não se configura
não existe e não gira à nossa volta
saleiro reconquistar o ócio a capacidade
não fazer nada e que é craque quinta
coisa que eu em mim às vezes estamos
muito que não fazer nada não fazer nada
importante
o ócio é importante a espera é a demora
é a capacidade de aproveitar não só as
férias mas os pequenos momentos da vida
em que nós estamos sem fazer nada em que
deixamos a nossa mente jogar e pensar em
outras coisas é muito importante porque
hoje em dia quando nós estamos no botão
de uvas hora e 11 horas mais dois pontos
a parceira o que nós fazemos
vemos no telemóvel e nós fizemos isso
hoje em dia quase intuitivamente quase
como flex
chegou ao ponto de uma cidade da holanda
eu estiver fora os semáforos bilhões
embaixo que para garantir que as pessoas
que não levantou os olhos do telemóvel e
que não olham se quer antes de
atravessar a rua por mensagem está vendo
o staff médico mas a verdade é que nós
fazemos isso hoje em dia de forma quase
flexível quase intuitiva e temos que
efetivamente recuperar a capacidade eo
talento não fazer nada e deixar a nossa
mente devagar lançamento na chave
comprar a imaginação ea e também comprar
empatia porque empatia não é chorar por
enfrentar o fmi concorda é
essencialmente uma projeção de algo que
nós é que estamos em nós próprios na
casa do euro como é viajar etc chorar
pelo iphan importante é chorar por uma
perda de nós próprios e empatia não é
isso
empatia é chorar uma perna e pelo
sofrimento dos outros principalmente
daqui há uns que são muito diferentes de
nós
[Aplausos]